you stars victoria pedretti and dylan
arnold are taking their on-screen
romance off screen a source confirms to
e.t the actors are dating in real life i
can't stop thinking about you and
victoria and dylan's relationship isn't
new the source says that the two have
been dating for a few months my issue is
that you're still flirting and i ask you
not i'm not flirting with you i'm
i'm begging you for food
the co-stars fueled dating rumors after
being spotted running errands together
over the weekend that's dylan and
victoria holding groceries and coffee
doing normal couple friendly activities
i don't want to give anything away that
takes the fun away of watching it and
their romance may come as no surprise to
you fans because the two had major
chemistry on screen if you want me to
shut up i will
i'm not trying to be an [ __ ]
i'm just trying to figure out
how i can focus when all i want is you
in season three of the netflix series
victoria stars as love quinn who is
married to penn badgley's character joe
goldberg while dylan plays their college
student neighbor theo engler but fun
fact he's older than victoria in real
life when love met theo there was an
instant spark between them so you got a
new town
new baby
new bakery
banging body
just uh you're just doing it all
victorian dylan also shared some steamy
scenes together
um are you sure
that relationship was just one of many
things that brought havoc to love and
joe's marriage in their new life in
suburbia and it's something penn and
victoria talked to e.t about back in
september what can the audience expect
from the fact that joe and love
are taking stalking and serial killing
to the suburbs and and they're becoming
parents you know there's new experiences
for them i think new levels of like
reckoning with who they are of course
neither of them have the tools to
to do this adequately right but like i
think for people
i i think it'll it'll be fun because
you're taking this device of of joe and
joe and love and applying into this new
world that is like um
i don't know it's just i you know it's
it is it is
alternately fun and profound i was very
excited about the notion of exploring
these characters in a marriage with a
child in suburbia that sounds cool
um so that was really exciting and the
circumstances that you know as i'm
saying really require them to change for
better or for work
you